buenas tardes hoy vengo a proponerles a
todos ustedes
un juego un juego una situación
quiero que por un momento cada uno de
ustedes se imaginen que somos parte de
un conjunto que somos parte de una
empresa
dentro de esta empresa
estamos buscando un personal nuevo
estamos buscando a alguien para nuestro
equipo de marketing
en esta búsqueda de personal
nos encontramos con un montón de
currículums nos llega una cantidad
enorme
en esa cantidad hay una en particular
que se destaca
lo pasamos a revisar
y nos encontramos dentro de un montón de
cosas con las principales
características
conocimiento y análisis de audiencia
conocimiento del manejo de diseño
gráfico y web
conocimiento y manejo de redes sociales
y sobre todo experiencia en esto
es perfecto para los que buscamos lo
contratamos
de hecho tanto
y nos fuimos
quedando con lo que teníamos en el
currículum que nos saltamos una parte
muy importante y son los datos
personales
pasamos a revisar esa hoja y no
encontramos con la siguiente
fecha de nacimiento 5 de mayo
de 1999
particularmente yo nunca fui muy bueno
con las matemáticas
pero 1999 son
19 años
qué dicen
es muy chico yo a ver no sé pero con 19
años esta experiencia que dice tener lo
creo
qué opinan ustedes los seguimos
contratando
arriesgamos nuestra búsqueda de personal
por esta persona de 19 años
los quiero dejar con esa idea con esa
pregunta mientras tanto les quiero
contar el otro lado de la historia
me levanto esta mañana resulta que ya
estaba cansado hace muchos días que
venía repartiendo currículums y no me
llegaba ni un solo mensaje ni una sola
llamada
decidido se ha resignado a aplicar el
último recurso y llamó a una de las
empresas en donde había dejado este
currículum
y pase lo siguiente
suena el teléfono me contesta a alguien
y pido hablar con el gerente de recursos
humanos
le pregunto qué pasó entre un curriculum
la verdad que estoy interesado en el
trabajo y después de cruzar dos o tres
palabras escucho lo siguiente
la verdad que es un buen curriculum es
interesante pues estamos buscando a
alguien con más experiencia
acá
me despido
dejo el teléfono
y me doy cuenta de que este fue mi
primer no le quiero dar la bienvenida a
señoras y señores hoy a nuestro primer
no
frustra molesta enoja y también nos hace
preguntar
como vamos a conseguir esta experiencia
que nos piden tener
si no tenemos la oportunidad de poder
generar la
voy hablar un poco en nombre de mi
generación
y de paso también contarles una historia
ya que a eso me dedico
somos millennials lo llaman así otros lo
llaman centenial ojos de internet porque
somos millennials algunas nos llaman la
generación ve en referencia a lo virtual
y así nos identifican muchas personas
somos los nacidos entre los 90 hasta los
2000 somos nativos digitales somos la
generación de la caja y de la hora
vivimos conectados y estamos presente en
casi todas las redes sociales
como facebook nada esperan facebook
facebook es para la familia como
instagram twitter snap chat
vivimos conectados vivimos en una
constante creciente de información todo
lo que necesitamos está al alcance de
nuestra mano o de nuestro teléfono o
tablet o computadora somos nativos
digitales
nuestra generación también es distinta
somos distintos y tenemos otras
aspiraciones me gustaría preguntarles a
los adultos que se encuentran acá
que querían ser cuando eran chicos
cuando eran jóvenes
estoy seguro de que alguno de ustedes me
podría decir yo quería ser abogado yo
quería ser abogada yo quería ser
ingeniero ingeniero quizás lo soy yo
quería ser médico quería
ser médica
bueno yo de chico
yo quería ser filmmaker
qué es ser filmmaker
perfil maker básicamente en resumidas
palabras es contar historias
a través de una cámara
los estoy viendo
de chico
me he encontrado con una plataforma con
youtube la de conocer
me he encontrado con los primeros
bloggers que son chicos que se dedicaban
a contar historias con una cámara y que
terminaron siendo mis referentes
yo quería ser como ellos ahora
imagínense
cuando lo plantea
no pasa nada estaba todo bien me dieron
me apoyaron y acá me encontré con mi
primer sí
no solo
me encontré con un si no solo me
encontré con el apoyo de mis padres
ya que tuve la suerte de que ellos me
dijeron que sí y no estuvo ese gerente
de la empresa de gerente de recursos
humanos que nos dijo que no es un rato
sino que estaban ellos
y me dieron una cámara
con esta cámara
comenzó algo que iba a cambiar el rumbo
de mi vida
con esta cámara
este juego que empezó hace muchos años
comenzó a ser parte de mi vida comenzó a
ser parte de mi trabajo
a día de hoy puedo decir que llevo ocho
años
contando historias como una cámara puedo
decir que llevo ocho años de experiencia
en mi currículum
ya sé no es lo mismo que trabajar ocho
años para una empresa para una grande
empresa considerada de favorecer al pero
después asegurar que durante esos años
me esfuerce para pulir cada detalle
tenías que conseguir ser como mis
referentes
tal fue así que no solo tuve esa suerte
de que vayan apoyado en su momento sino
que también tuve otro golpe de suerte
me encontraba trabajando menos me
encontraba jugando
alguien se detuvo a mirar
me dijeron que si de luego y me abrieron
las puertas a un montón y a un montón y
un montón de experiencias
hoy cuento historias
me dedico a esto
es en el hito de 11 años que querían ser
filmmaker creció
y se encontró con un montón de cosas en
el camino
se encontró con diseño se encontró con
experiencias
y ese chico pasa a ser un creador de
contenido
hoy me dedico a esto
quiero preguntarles
qué pasaría
si miráramos a los jóvenes distintos
qué pasaría si comenzando si comenzamos
a darles una oportunidad
qué pasaría si le damos el sí
para que puedan empezar a regresar sus
sueños
gracias s si también me dieron en su
momento y gracias a la confianza que
fueron depositando durante los años a
día de hoy me puedo parar acá
y hablar adelante de todos ustedes para
decirles que hay afuera y por qué no acá
adentro
hay un montón de chicos que están
esperando su oportunidad que están
esperando su momento que están esperando
que le digan que sí
quiero de cada uno de ustedes se
cuestionen y que piense cuantas veces
le dijimos a nuestro hijo a nuestra
hermana a nuestro nieto a gastón sobrino
línea que haces en esa computadora todo
el día y conectado a todo el día metido
a clases nada productivo acaso no
estamos haciendo algo productivo
muchas veces juzgamos sin saber lo que
está pasando dentro
y dentro de un mundo estamos conectados
estamos trabajando no solo estamos
jugando que a veces puede ser
sino que también estamos aprendiendo
estamos aprendiendo a encontrar nuestro
sí
somos la nueva generación somos
distintos sí somos distintos su
generación
con el empuje de años con su trayectoria
con su largo camino recorrido
con su capacidad para poder diferenciar
lo bueno de lo malo quizás tan solo con
verlo y por otro lado nuestra generación
con una nueva mirada con un fuerte
empuje con ganas de cumplir sus sueños
con ganas de conseguir sus objetivos y
con una capacidad de uso de tecnológico
nato
ambas por separados son excelentes son
geniales
pero quiero que piensen
qué pasaría si las unimos
qué pasaría si mezclamos estas potencias
estas dos generaciones
y creamos algún conjunto
me gustaría
que se queden con esta idea
juntos somos imparables
su generación y la nuestra pueden ser
uno
antes de cerrar
quiero que piense en algo
y es que estamos en un momento perfecto
para mezclar estas dos generaciones
para romper paradigmas
para crear algo nuevo en conjunto y para
comprender
entre ambos
la importancia de decir que si muchas
gracias